hello and welcome to my latest leaders
briefing I want to start by saying how
shocked and deeply saddened we were by
the incredibly sad passing of a late
Majesty that Queen Elizabeth II I want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
residents and businesses and Community
groups for the tremendous ways in which
they paid their respects uh to Queen
Elizabeth and those who came into our
buildings and signed the books of
condolence and those who laid flowers
and also people who came to the local
proclamation of King Charles III at Mill
Lane at our district council offices
it's been a tremendously difficult and
sad time for the whole nation but I'm
really proud of the way that Northeast
Derbyshire has come together to pay our
respects to our fantastic at Lake Queen
now you may be wondering where I am I'm
currently stood here in kilimash in
kilimash active which is our Leisure
Center here in the village uh you may be
aware that a few a couple of years ago
we took it over from the parish council
and brought it into the district
council's portfolio of leisure centers
and almost straight away we embarked on
a 1.9 million pound major Redevelopment
and red refurbishment of the facility
it's really nearly finished now it's
just simply the final finishing touches
and although we hope to open today
unfortunately due to unforeseen
circumstances we had to push that back
to tomorrow Saturday the 1st of October
we're really sorry and we're really
grateful for everyone's patience with us
and we look forward to opening the doors
and welcoming you through them tomorrow
but there's all there's a whole raft of
other improvements we've made we've
opened up the reception area we've got a
cafe in and the library very very close
to it so that people can have a coffee
and get a book out we've got a soft play
area an 80s station gym a changing in
places toilet and a whole raft of other
huge improvements to this facility and
it's part of our wider commitment to
Leisure Leisure across the district as
well we have four Leisure centers in the
district and they're all benefiting from
a total of 27 million pounds worth of
investment that we put in over the past
few years so it really is a key
commitment for us as an Administration
and I hope residents are seeing the
improvements at first hand in their in
their local Leisure centers one of the
things you may notice when you're
walking around the new killer Marsh
Active Sports Center is the Platinum
Fitness week which we've named to honor
and commemorate a fantastic amazing
70-year reign of a late Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II
sticking with the theme of killer Marsh
we also have secured a hundred thousand
pound grants uh from the safest streets
fund which is a community Safety project
to invest in the skate park which is
next door to where I am here uh in the
in the Sports Center in kilimarsh active
and that that will be a real Improvement
as well and it'll be it'll help solidify
this this wider Improvement that we're
making to the uh the the Leisure Center
here and we know that young people have
been asking us uh for improvements to
the to the skatepark for quite a while
now so we're really really pleased with
support from our police and crime
commissioner Anthony Foster to have
received that funding and able to
benefit and hopefully we'll be sharing
uh we'll be sharing our plans as to how
we want to improve that skatepark in the
next next few months and we'll look
forward to seeing that those plans
progress and now sticking with a theme
of funding we've also been applying
recently for two significant rounds of
funding from the government the first is
the UK share Prosperity fund
um which which we're expected to receive
around almost 2.6 million pounds and
we've submitted our investment plan to
the government which details how we
intend to spend that money over the next
three years and it's in things like
improving play areas improving shop
Frontage improving public realm Works
improving uh Village halls and Community
facilities we really want to demonstrate
the residents that they can see visible
improvements for this funding so you can
find out more about that on our website
and and we'll hopefully be successful in
the in the funding application uh in
October and then we'll start we're
already starting to uh to to progress
the different ways in which we want to
spend that that important funding and
then also we've recently back in the
earlier part of the summer we applied
for over 17 million pounds to elevate
eckington so that was our bid as part of
the leveling up on the government's
leveling up for and that would be some
major town center regeneration in
eckington complete redesign of the town
center and improvements as well as a
sort of super Park if you like at
Lansbury Road play area so we we haven't
found out yet whether that's been
successful but we don't necessarily know
whether we will be or not but in any
case all of the work that we've done to
prepare that bid means that in future if
we're not successful this time we can
keep applying and making sure that we
get that vital funding to help really
improve efforts and Town Center which I
know has been on a lot of people's minds
in epoxy for a long time now over in
dronfield sports center we recently ran
together with a DWP a job spare to help
local people find local jobs in the drum
field area really thanks to everyone who
came to exhibit and show their
organizations off and to all the
prospective job Hunters who came I
really hope that was useful it's a key
commitment for us as an Administration
to hold regular jobs Affairs to help
local people find local jobs so I'm
really really pleased to do that I'm
sure there'll be more coming up to stay
tuned to our website and our social
media to find out about other job
players we'll be doing if you're looking
for a job yourself so this past month
we've been supporting organic September
which is a fantastic scheme which helps
encourage people to be more organic in
their in their shopping choices and
helps you know promote a better
environment and and helps to deal with
some of the issues around climate change
there's loads more information on our on
our website around how you can shop more
organically in terms of clothes and food
and all those sorts of things so please
do check out our website for more
information on that one now you may also
have been following recently in the
local media that our area so at
Derbyshire and Derby City and
Nottinghamshire and Nottingham City has
been successful in securing a Devolution
deal from the government now this is a
30-year deal with the government that's
worth a total of 1.14 billion for our
region and there's various other funding
mechanisms and schemes that would go
with that to support things like
Brownfield housing and things like
climate change and all those sorts of
things in theory and looking at it at
face value it looks like good news for
our region it you know in East Midlands
has long have been underserved in terms
of investment in infrastructure and
education and those sorts of things so
in theory it should be good the one key
challenge is that the in order to access
that deal the area the region is
required to have an elected mayor now
that doesn't change anything in terms of
how the councils are run you will still
have a district council as well
Northeast average District Council
you'll still have Derbyshire County
Council doing the same things that we
already already do the mayor would have
powers handed down from government to to
to to deal with things on a sort of
regional level if you like within our
region and I know views really vary on
on elected Mayors and I you know I'm not
I'm not the biggest fan myself but I
recognize that actually in order to
access that really important investment
in our region it may be the sacrifice
that we have to make you'll be hearing
more and more about this over time
there'll be consultation with residents
and and you'll be able to find out a bit
more about it but that's just to give
you the heads up and stay tuned for more
updates on that moving forward finally
just just want to say please do come
down and have a look at kilimash active
are almost brand new Leisure Center here
in killer Marsh when it's when it's open
we'll really look forward to welcoming
you and hopefully we can sign you up for
a membership uh and have a go on the
spin studio or the or the gym or even
just go and bring the kids and go on the
soft play area it really is a fantastic
facility and we're really looking
forward to showing it off to Not Just
Killer Marsh residents but residents
from across the whole District I'll look
forward to seeing you next month until
then just to say stay tuned to our
website and our social media channel for
more updates as they happen we look
forward to seeing you next month
foreign